Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab, the podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen, we are here
for a historic confrontation.
And on today's podcast we'll
start with a little comeback.
I want to tell you about an
event Robert and I did recently.
Right here in Wny sees new green space.
We built a little boxing ring with ropes
and everything. We asked IRA glass,
who you're hearing to
be our boxing referee,
about 250 people showed up and Robert
and I decided to go head to head federal
once and for all the debate
radio versus television,
which is superior.
Hmm. So let's get started on
in this corner,
Robert, the crusher bro Edge
[inaudible].
I got to wear Silk Luxembourg
in the opposite corner.
The one the only Chad Boom Abbott, right
[inaudible]
and I got to where they're very stylish.
Red Boxing trunks with a hook in
real boxing. So here's how it went.
When you went five rounds, the rules
were pretty simple. I play something.
Then Robert would play something
thing and then Ira and the audience would
judge round. One question topic was,
which is better at pictures, radio
or television? We'll just jump to the
results just to give you a taste of all.
Alright. Television is the winner.
Good.
Brown too. Which medium
is better at emotions?
Is it radio
[inaudible]
or is it television?
Oh,
still have to do rounds.
We were tied and so really just to
speed things up here we went three more
rounds or not thread. Three various
questions and when we got to round five,
which was on the question of which
is more fun, radio or TV? Well,
here's what happened. I declared
television in the winter.
No,
what's that riot? Do you want to have a
recount? We can do a recap. I want to,
I want, I want them to riot.
[inaudible]
you're familiar with the
concept of a sore loser.
Radio doesn't have to win. How much more
dignity is there to this whole event?
We were in a radio station, IRA, we
have to wait. We can't wait to hear.
We can't win anywhere.
[inaudible]
all right, I'll take
a poll again. No radio
[inaudible].
I suddenly realized why they don't do
recounts in elections and television.
You guys are saying
hi. It was a draw.
It was a draw. Everybody won
that night. You had no radio. No,
I still refused to believe.
So then we decided, well,
okay so we took off our robes in our
glove and then we sat down and say,
well let's just put it all together
here. Like there are rules for making TV,
there are rules for making radio and
how are they different? And IRA began
all the rules of what we do on the radio,
especially on our show where the stories
have narrative motion where there's
characters in motion and
there's a conflict that
announces itself pretty quickly
and the people have to be treated.
Somebody has to be pretty
charming and you can relate to,
it's like our show on the radio
pretends to be a show where where,
where we're documenting everyday life,
but when not actually what we're doing
is we're getting sort of regular people
who are in really,
really unusual and interesting situations
that would be worth putting on the
radio.
And the thing that having pictures let
us do was to actually eliminate the need
for a surprising pot line.
And Co let us just have moments
that we knew would be dramatic.
Like a guy's kid comes home from the army,
comes home from Iraq and you know,
like we had specific moments we were
going out to shoot but they didn't have to
surprise in exactly the same way.
And really a lot of the thing is kind
of staring at people and in a way that
just is just anti radio
like it was, is just,
is that an entire hour that just
been very difficult to do on radio.
A lot of what we did on TV, I
think you could have done on radio,
there's like a hugeness to the
radio to the intimacy of the radio.
Like when you're in the actual um,
credit little hospital room and a not
so fancy hospital in Washington state.
And it's a real guy and his sort of semi
photogenic mom and he's like a little
bit of a stiff and she, I
dunno, like and then the,
and then they performed the
scene and you see them really,
they're not iconic, weird way.
Like, like something about the,
the specifics of staring at them and of
that room and you recognize kind of the
whole, the hospital tray. It
just plays really differently.
Whereas on radio it would
be weirdly a mythic.
If you think about that piece,
that piece that you played with
where it's the dad and the kid,
there's something really epic about it.
Like it's intimate and it's epic because
he like with his deep voice and her and
her sort of symbolic like
kidness become iconic
Irish talking about a piece which had
an unfairly cute daughter up in that.
Why don't we just play it for the father
with a really deep voice. This was an,
I think if we played it in round two,
this is from John Biewen at first it's
physical like any great love those eyes,
those hands, those thighs
really.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Hey Harper, what's a kitty cat? Say
the weight of them on your
lap. Climbing on your head.
Nobody writes pop songs
about that. Touch that field.
Sure.
What you're going to [inaudible]
I'm going to listen to you,
but riding around inside that little body,
there's this person
over here, budding mind.
He'll do anything to touch
my craft.
So this small body becomes the
source of your biggest fears.
The child to flesh is
vulnerable. So you are too.
I do, but my favorite part of that
hearing you all look wonderful in our,
in your outfits. This is sad.
I can't wait to learn what all of
you want to be when you grow up.
Can I have some milk?
How old are you now girl?
Come on.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I'm scared,
but you have to let go. Let her go.
Little by little she said that Kayla
said something mean about me. She said,
dad, it's okay. Was that way too,
in that way in which her
body was never for you.
Next message. Hi Daddy. It's Harper. Um,
we're going to be out like on a
Ga. Oh girl. After gay down. Um,
just call me on my cell phone. Like
if anything happened or anything,
I'll call you whenever
I come home. Okay, bye.
[inaudible].
So girl, how old are you going
to be your next birthday? 13.
And have you and your mom
talked about, you know,
the talk? Yeah. Do you think
you and I should have the talk?
No, no, no. Good.
So that was a piece called scared from
John [inaudible] and thanks to him and to
Harper Bun and to the third coast audio
festival. And now back to the event.
I think one of the deep
differences is when you watch the,
it is an act of staring. So you're,
you're in a chair or standing and you're
looking across a space at a box with a
square, and then the square
has some images and you,
your options are to look
away or to look at it.
You also know that between
you and [inaudible], there
could be lots of business.
Someone could come by, a cat
could go by, a child could go buy,
a dog could go by, or if something could
catch your eye and you'd Click it away.
So there is a stare in TV in the radio.
Often people either clamp something on
either ear or if they don't do that and
they're just listening to the
radio, there is a, um, there is uh,
an intimate kind of sharing
where if the radio is describing,
the person listening starts to paint in
voluntarily just because they helplessly
picture the words you're saying
and the painting in your head,
first of all belongs to
you. And it's not a stare.
It's actually very unlike a stare.
And there's more when you are
coauthoring, which is what you're doing,
the story you're being told,
there is more room in there
for that story in a way.
But when you stare,
you do get to see things that you wouldn't
know that you wouldn't find yourself,
that you couldn't imagine.
But there is a coolness to the stare
and a warmness to the radio that just
travels. And they were very
advantages and disadvantages to both.
And I see, I the other,
the, the, like I, I'd
see all that and felt all that
when we were making TV. Like the,
the other thing that always struck me
as a huge difference is that to get an
emotional moment on TV,
like we could make an emotional
moment and just like you said,
you have people's faces and
they communicate so much
and communicate just as
much as the voice does. Um, but
to make an emotional moment on TV,
it's almost like we would have to like
erect a scaffolding for it to happen and
build to the moment and they'd have
to be like fast action, fast action,
fast action, cutting, cutting, cutting.
And then we'd have to slow it down so you
could feel the slowness and then there
could be slower sorts of emotion and
feeling and the music would change it.
It was sort of like a much
bigger orchestration job, um,
in the way it had to be photographed
and handled. Whereas on radio,
it has such emotion as the
default position like it
because it's the thing that
it's going to do when it's not even
trying to do anything is communicate a lot
of feeling and a lot of
intimacy. You know, like we,
we can send that anybody with a tape
recorder and if they can talk to somebody,
they'll get that and the sound of the
person's voice will carry out this
feeling. And, and that seemed to be
just in a, just an a a huge difference.
And then people were more able to open
up on the radio to work with sort of an
answer or thing when it isn't like a
camera crew on lights and like, you know,
we were shooting very pretty. So there's
a lot of people and um, versus a bit,
by the time we finished a
second season, they were,
when we started our first
season, I thought, well,
we'll get the same percentage of
people who open up on radio and TV.
But by the time we got to the
end of the second season, uh,
Lisa and Nancy and the other producers
when they really wanted to get down with
people,
we would film part of the interview and
then they would just tape part of the,
they just take the person off and they
were taped part of the interview just
with a tape recorder. Just them. Yeah.
And then we would use that part in the
part where you see pictures of other
stuff and, and yeah.
So we totally tricked it out to get the
kinds of quotes that we wanted because
we weren't getting the quotes we wanted
while the camera was rolling. Sometimes.
Let me ask you both the questions
since you both have done radio and TV,
in many cases, the same
story on radio and TV. Um,
how has the experience of doing radio
being or being behind the camera different
than being behind the
microphone? Cause I have this,
I always sort of joke with him.
I have this experience every time
I see him on TV, it tweaks me.
It's weird because I'm like,
who is that guy? He's not,
he's not the the Robert that I know from
the studio cause he's the Robert in the
studio and the Robert like in this ring.
And I love the fact that we're having
this quiet chat in a boxing ring.
He's kind of like this oversize
outsized emotional duties. Like,
like just huge gestures. But on TV
it's all like, he keeps it small.
He kind of, he kind of brings it in.
And there's something about the scale
that it's really interesting to me when
you see somebody do both, you know,
I mean, do you wonder what I wonder.
You always said
yes. He says when they're, you
know, he just says it's so little,
you're so tight. You're so you learn,
here's the thing. The camera
goes and looks right at you.
And so if you were to give
a big Cheshire cat grin,
if you were to make a broad gesture
in the box, it's just too big.
So you just learned somewhere
along the line that, um,
that you, you do scale
it down because you're,
you're so big in this virtual space,
but you're bigger and the
radio, cause I always say,
I tell people like when you're
performing on the radio,
it's like you're in front of a camera
and the camera's always on close up and
like use your inside voice,
you know, kind of, you,
you had to get the desk thing. Well that
was just in the first season. I mean,
well, the concede of it was we couldn't
figure out how to put me on TV. Like,
like, where should I be or should I
even be, should you ever see me at all?
And then it seemed kind of kind of,
um, artsy that you would never see me.
You know what I mean?
My favorite version of the different ways
that you would see me would be that I
would walk into each story at the end,
like Rod Serling and go man in a woman,
you know, but I felt like I
could perform that too. Um,
but was it a scale thing? Where was it
that you needed to feel somehow? No, no.
We put, we did the desk cause we just
thought like after trying to run a week,
we shot all sorts of different
things as little tests and, and,
and all of them trying to run away
from conventions of a host on TV.
But truthfully, like everything's
been done. If you're a host on TV,
like you know your own
real desk that's been done,
you in a card just talking to the camera,
you're walking down the
street with the subject.
You just like every sort of casual
and non casual version has been done.
And so we thought, well let's instead
of running away from the convention,
so let's run towards them. What's,
take the corniest convention and let's
do the desk and the suit and the mug and
like a microphone and let's like have a
build one of those desks that only exist
on television that doesn't exist in
nature. That's like those shiny desks.
And um, and then let's put it outside.
Let's just put it somewhere random.
We had never, I had never seen the,
there's apparently a Monte python
thing where they were the anchor man is
outside. I didn't know that you see
even that had been done. But um,
so we would just take it to incredibly,
like the idea is like one day it's in a
factory for and the next day it's by a
nuclear power station and you know, and
so that was the idea. It was just let's,
let's make something big in
photographic, but why, why,
why the trouble you said you couldn't
figure out how to be on TV because like
this American life like to identify it
has like weirdly just it's imprinting a
kind of intimacy and
very many people I know.
And it's something weirdly anti intimate
about the image that we ended up making
with me in it. And in the
second season because of that.
Instead of shooting it that way, we took,
we bought a lot of flip camera for $149
at best buy and we shot all the things
of me with that and we just go on the
subway and I would just shoot myself
talking to the camera and saying
my thing. What about [inaudible]
audience?
I sent that the the radio audience is
a completely different audience in a
consistently different mood than the
television audience do you think?
I mean I do.
I different like as in different people
or different when there are different
people,
but commercial television tends to get a
slightly older group and radio at least
this radio, the Miss American
life and radio does this.
It gets a bit of a younger
audience, but beyond that,
I think the radio audience gets
the impression that they know,
you know you and the TV
audience because of the staring,
they will respect you. They'll do yo,
so you want TV thing that is there,
they'll notice you.
They don't presume to begin or
have a conversation with you.
Whereas on the radio, they presume
to have a conversation with,
you're saying from your experience
being an MPR and being on ABC,
you know where we see it actually we
sort of see the flip side of that is when
we take over Terry Gross a
spot, uh, Fridays at three,
which we do a couple of times a year,
you would not believe the vitriol,
the venomous flow of hatred as if we
have kidnapped Terry literally kidnapped
her and taken and locked her into the
closet there. Terry grows, you know,
so it's, it's, it's a rerun show.
They've heard it already. It
doesn't matter. It's part of their
routine on Fridays at three. What do I do?
I do her. And who were these
two people and what are they
doing? No, no, they don't
listen to it. They just like,
they bite it.
I had to say that the biggest thing I've
ever done on TV was just two weeks ago.
And that is that I appeared on the
Khobar Rapport and I'd been on,
I'd been on the daily show, had been
on Letterman. I'd been on, um, on, uh,
Conan.
But there's something about people's
relationship to Steve and Kobe are where
like complete strangers walk up to me on
the street and caught me on the street
and like a lot of them and it's
like, Hey, saw you on Colbert.
They feel like they feel like it
was us against him or something.
I can name such a like they'll like, like,
like they just want me to know like they
watch Cole Bear and they were with me,
you know, and,
and it was a cute because you survived
Cobra or with you because they,
you're part of the cold beer club both
like I survived it. They're like, hey,
you did okay sort of
with go bear, you know,
like very much just like it was like I
was in a boxing match with Steven Coe
bear and, and they, they
appreciated it and, and,
and they want to tell me about it like
in a way that I've found really Gulf way.
The maths may be our last question
is, is, is the glamour question. Um,
there has been for years associated
with being on TV. There's this sense of,
Ooh, wow. Kind of thing.
And then radio was sort of a other thing
you could do if you were in a car or
cutting carrots. And I, I get the sense
that that's actually switched a bit.
So Steve Cobe bear could
almost have, has a relief.
I don't know why I say this,
it's Steve called Berra who does
wonderful sight gags and you know,
but there is something about that show
even more than the other one that does
seem like,
I don't know why it seems like
the best radio that I hear
people have such a personal relationship
with him in a way that, that,
I dunno. I mean I feel that way
about a handful of shows, you know,
I feel that way about,
about the draw, you know,
I felt that way about Friday
night lights, you know,
greatest show on television
except for the second season,
except for the one thing, the second
season was a downer. Low water. I mean,
I mean, they're good. They're good.
I mean, I guess I'm saying like, I,
you know, I feel that about other things
in television besides Stephen Colbert.
I think that's the bond you feel
with any show that you really love.
You feel like you're,
I was in the subway and I saw an inspector
from the wire that Millie mean guy,
um, who, um, the Polish guy who
wants to buy the, uh, yeah, yeah,
I'll try to, I saw of the actor
who plays val check and I, I,
he was sitting there and I was holding
the pole and I thought, I just,
I guess I'll honor him by my quiet
gaze. I won't say anything, you know,
and my heart was beating and everything.
I was thinking I was going to tell my
wife to get you eyes on this. Uh, and um,
but I didn't.
Okay.
If I'd seen Steven Cole bear or if I
didn't know you and saw you or you,
I think
he says with the state, find it
more approachable. I think I'd find,
I think I might dare, I might say, oh, hi.
Or something like that. Yeah,
it's true. Well that's good to,
on the radio if you're performing it
right, you're exactly human size. Like,
like if you're on the radio, if you're
doing it correctly, I think you are,
there's a one to one scale. Just you
said really though that it was myth,
mythic and epic too though that moment
in that story. Yeah, no, I, you know,
that's true. I guess it's a contradiction.
[inaudible] I, you know, I
think one of the things that,
that this American life did was they
made true stories feel like fairy tales.
Like every, and it has
to do with the music.
It has to do with the way they're
constructed and with the surprise and the
characters that you meet, it's, it feels
like a, it feels like a fairy tale.
It feels like, like you're
entering me on TV and on radio.
I mean mostly on the radio. I'm thinking
straight, early, early, you know,
just that show coming out of
everything else that was at that time.
Suddenly these characters did
seem large. They seemed like, um,
sort of epic and huge and, but
yet sort of like in the bed,
embedded in their breasts,
the same sort of desires and fascinations
and fears that the rest of us had.
So that was new for me to hear that.
So I don't know. I mean there the,
it gets confusing when you
use the techniques of fiction
storytelling techniques
of movie making with true stories you
can invest true reality with a sense of
largeness and a sense of sweep that that
you would only expect to see like in a
movie theater. That's kind of
the cool thing about it I think.
And then there's the wire.
Thank you all for coming.
Thanks for coming up.
[inaudible] want to thank
Carrie Hellman for helping.
Definitely want to think of green space
people from making it very cool space
available. Green space means the
part of the building at WDC. Yeah,
we have live events which is where that
just was inaugurated that very week.
So I was already logged your roll out.
Maybe do one of those and also to
the hungry marching band because um,
they made a lot of big loud
noise. Easy. Yes. Thanks.
And also we want to thank the people
that help make radio lab possible.
That would be number one. This is just
Lone Alpha p Sloan Foundation number two,
Mr Corporation for public broadcasting
and number three Mr National Science.
Yes, that a foundation. Then I'm
Jad Abumrad I Robert College.
Thanks for listening.